He's the dentist son who grew up to become the world's youngest billionaire.
In the mid two thousands,
mark Zuckerberg created a website that defines a generational website.
You almost certainly use yourself.
The bad wolf is facebook today.
It dominates the Internet.
It has more active users than the populations of China and India combined at the
time of writing.
It's worth around half a trillion dollars.
It's also at the center of some massive control disease that have dominated the
headlines.
Yup.
How much to most of us know about the man behind the business?
Maybe you've seen the movie,
the social network,
which reimagines Mark Zuckerberg is a kind of Lex luthor of the internet using
his genius to crush his enemies.
This elements of truth to that to be sure,
but the real mark Zuckerberg is far more interesting,
far more nuanced and far more tragically flawed.
Rich,
brilliant,
idealistic.
This is the story of how one privileged kid from small town,
New York created a digital empire.
I really need to see all his good intentions collapsed to dust.
If you were living among the clapboard houses and leafy streets of dobbs ferry,
New York in the mid nineties,
they would have been one neighborhood kid who you were sure was going to go far
and that would've been mocked soccer bag,
born in nearby white plains on May the 14th,
1984 young mark was a veritable prodigy,
taught Atari basic programming language as a child by age 12.
He was creating sprawling games from his friends.
Childhood drawings lies mid teens,
Middleton,
early messaging app called Zach and after this allowed the family to communicate
with his dad's dentistry business online in real time.
When mark ended up transferring to these super prestigious Phillips Exeter
Academy for Graduate Computing Course,
no one was in the least bit surprised this Aka bags had always been a family of
brain boxes that Edward was a dentist and mum,
Karen was a psychiatrist and the family always encouraged learning in their four
children.
But mark,
he was something else,
a polyglot.
It taught himself how to speak French,
Hebrew that in an ancient Greek,
he was captain of the fencing team.
He devoured classic literature along with the friends,
Adams Angelou.
It even programmed a media player so advanced that it sparked a bidding war
between Microsoft and AOL.
In short,
mark was one of those privileged kids you can tell are destined to forever roll
doubles sixes in the game of life.
He had the talent to go far and he had the competitive drive to on a form around
this time.
He actually listed defeating Nemeses as his hobby.
So when this woman begins,
lends into place at Harvard in 2002,
it was just another step on that great long staircase of privilege that led to
the heaven of a high flying job and day.
I'm in the Hamptons only this particular staircase.
It came with a stumbling block.
This was one that would initially trip 19 year old mark before accidentally
showing him the how decline far higher than it ever dreams that I'm of that
block.
Well,
that was loneliness.
So here's the thing about going to Harvard.
As a small town genius,
you'll suddenly surrounded by other geniuses for the first time in your life,
and some of these geniuses might be so clever that you start to look a little
less special and just a bit more ordinary.
In the 2008 profile rollingstone claims that this was exactly what happens.
Mark Zuckerberg isolated among so many other Harvard brainiacs,
he retreated into programming and Ben's ending his social life for an online
world where he could still shine.
He created a popular site called course match for his fellow students,
which gave them an insight into what made people tick,
but course match.
It wasn't the work of a genius.
It didn't even make him stand out from the crowd as he so desperately craved.
No,
he would have to wait until his sophomore year to do that because that was when
he created the little something known as facemash and excluded Harvard society.
In October 2003,
Mark Zuckerberg sat in his dorm room,
drunk and alone and consumer by depression.
It just been jilted by one,
Jessica,
and like every young man,
unlucky in love,
he turned to alcohol to Numb the pain of existence as a morosely blogged about
the bitch who had betrayed him.
Nineteen year old Zuckerberg began sneaking through Kirkland dorms,
facebook.
That's Harvard Lingo for the online photo directories of students that each dorm
keeps his ego winded soccer bag that has negative thoughts flow into his blog.
Some of these people have pretty horrendous facebook picks.
He wrote,
I almost want to put some of these faces next to pictures of farm animals and
debit people vote on,
which is more attractive.
The more alcoholics,
acrobatic consumers,
the more he began to take the idea seriously.
Maybe not with a farm animals,
but why not put up two pictures of students and have other students vote on who
is the hottest.
Before long Zuckerberg was thinking of.
His idea is more than just a way of lashing out at a world that it wounded him.
It would be an epic prank,
one that would no doubt go down in Harvard history by the early morning hit
successfully hacked all of Harvard's dorm directories,
scraping away private to use a day runs.
Blogging about is praying every step of the way before the sun rose facemash.
It was live in no time at all.
Four hundred and 50 people had viewed the site 22,000 times years later.
The 2010 movie,
the social network would suggest facebook itself grew out of facemash,
which isn't quite true,
but facemash does remain key to understanding soccer bag,
the scale and speed of the positive response to his prank site.
It opened his eyes as he would later say,
we have a lot more voyeuristic than I would have thought.
It's a revelation he would assume leverage into huge business success.
No,
the one event was guaranteed that cold October night,
facemash was only live for a few hours before Harvard shut it down and hit
Zuckerberg with the mother of all disciplinary actions.
He could be suspended or expelled,
and then what would his mom and his dad think?
Yes.
For all of the stress that it caused him good,
that came out of the facemash debacle,
having gained something invaluable,
he was special again.
He was no longer a nobody.
He was a computer genius and to pranks to hero Zaka bug was even able to
leverage his new notoriety and to a date with a medical students called
Priscilla Chan and trust me,
that is a name you are going to be hearing again and again.
On November the 19th,
2003 Harvard's disciplinary board.
It's dropped its privacy violation,
charges against Zaka back the prank stuff,
but water a bottle of champagne and cracked it open with his room is to
celebrate.
Finally,
you had a place in the world again,
all through 2003.
Harvard had been a campus that was buzzing with ideas.
These were the heady days of web.
Two point zero and social technologies were clearly going to be the next big
thing.
All they needed was for someone to harness them,
someone with the brains and the talent to pull technology and all human desire
to connect into the first great social website.
Someone like Divya Narendra and some brilliant New York kid of Indian descent,
Narendra was in his junior year at Harvard when he had a brainwave.
Imagine if you could take Harvard's many facebooks and combine them all into a
single site.
It would have a social section,
the dating section,
and it would combine all the advantages of real life interaction with the
advantages of the facebooks.
The name,
foot Narendra is John's online.
Facebook.
Well,
last was Harvard connection.
Bloody Narendra was not an ad mat still.
He managed in April to rope into identical twins,
Tyler and Cameron Winkle Voss.
They were going to act as his money man,
his team in place and render it now.
Just needed to compute a guy to write the code and pull everything together.
It was at this point that the ambitious young entrepreneur about facemash in
November of 2003 and a render and the winco bosses.
They contacted the now notorious because look good bags.
You asked if he would help them in that project,
so he jumped at the chance emails from the time that they should release the
full of positivity.
He told them it would take 10 hours and that he wouldn't be finished soon.
Narendra and his cohorts,
they rub their hands with glee,
would only be a matter of time before they will all filthy rich as November
ticked over into December.
Zuckerberg abandoned his work on Harvard connection.
It's still though.
He promised new renderer that it would be finished soon,
but he began to start work and his own project.
This new project was a harvard connection,
but without all the extra crap it would be one based on psychological insights
from facemash on January the 11th,
2004.
Look at the quantity registered the new site with his web provider and with that
the facebook Dashcam appeared and the Internet's records for the first.
The very next day is talk about a approach to his friend.
Did Water Savarin Zoo,
helped finance the project is everyone agreed to front of thousand dollars and
it would later say that he owned.
He caved in off.
Zuckerberg assured him that they'd be able to use the new site to get light.
That January the 14th is acrobatic.
Finally stopped stringing,
render along in a face to face meeting.
He told him that he needed to find a new program at their Indra,
pleaded with him to stay,
but doug,
he was already gone and the last forensic weeks before the facebook launched,
it dawned on soccer bag this,
he was going to fail a module on art in the time of Augustus.
Therefore,
he hatched a classic Zaka Bec scheme in no time at all.
He knocked up a website and encouraged his classmates,
do sham materials on it.
Within the 30 minutes of the science going live,
it amassed enough materials and function as his own private crib sheet soccer
bag past the module on February the fourth,
2004.
The facebook.com finally went live smart so that you can innovative it looked
shore to be the hottest new site on campus.
As you already know,
though,
these success of Zuckerberg and sovereigns projects,
it would not be confined to only Harvard.
The early days of facebook and now legendary.
Over 4,000 people signed up in the first two weeks.
By May,
almost 200,000 people are on board.
These figures are still impressive today,
but in the innocent days of 2004,
they were actually phenomenal.
Yeah.
Does not get the early success.
It was accompanied by a strange defensiveness in the student paper,
the Harvard Crimson.
He published an open letter describing how he always went out of his way to help
people,
you know,
before wheeling around and attacking the renderer with all guns blazing by the
end of the article,
had managed to turn his own intellectual property theft and see a scenario where
he was the victim,
not that anything about Zuckerberg,
his outward appearance screamed victim Sama.
He was renting an apartment in Palo Alto and trying to crack Silicon Valley.
One of his last acts before leaving Harvard was to ask Severin for an additional
$20,000 for the site and for him to join back in California.
Savrin said yes to the first and to know to the seconds this would not work out
well for him.
That June the first facebook headquarters appeared in a house on the Jennifer
wait.
It was the punk into mass that Zika Zuckerberg had always dreamed of.
The teams spent all day drinking,
bear and listening to green day and all night programming,
Zuckerberg,
even soap to you,
carrying around a fencing foil,
sort of like a genre but reborn as an entitled kid from New York State,
but it would take something more to catapult to the new social network into the
big time something or maybe someone that's someone was napster co founder,
Justin Timberlake,
not ready.
That would be Shawn Parker.
He's played by Justin Timberlake in the elementary and movie.
Sean Parker just happened to be living a few blocks away from the never ending
facebook Frat party,
but I've always known to suck a bag through sovereign who'd introduced them at a
dinner one day his doctor bag just happened to be walking past his house when
Parker came outside and the to recognize one another.
Now,
if you want to pinpoint the moments when Zuckerberg went from node with the
dreams you guy on a course to becoming the world's youngest billionaire,
well this is probably it.
Pocket became the facebooks connection to silicon valley's big money elite.
It was a connection,
even Zaka bags,
habit of arriving at meetings in his pajamas,
could not break in August,
pay co founder Peter Teal became the science first,
a big investor giving them a cash injection of $500,000.
Suddenly with that things they were looking very serious and we mean that hair
in more ways than one around the time he always coming on board.
Savrin was not just being shown the door that he was being thrown through it in
July of 2004 savarin fruits,
facebook's accounts off to soccer,
back fail to match his $20,000 investments.
Soccer back responded by transferring all of the facebooks assets to a new
version of the company that was headquartered in Delaware.
This is both cups ever announced and rendered his old stock.
Worthless.
Sovereign would later say that Zuckerberg screwed me by December of 2004,
the facebook was pulling in 1 million users.
Pocket took over as presidents and dinner.
Early 2005.
He forced through a name change from this point on the site,
would simply be known as facebook and they have that.
You have venture capital firms sell apart and is invested.
Twelve point $7,000,000 in facebook.
The condition though was that the company has to expand beyond just the Ivy
League schools.
That September the site was opened to all colleges and high schools across the
United States by Christmas.
That will five point 5 million users and Zuckerberg,
well Zaka bag was riding a high yahoo at MTV networks were both fighting to buy
stakes in the rising company and the money was absolutely ruling in the one
major hiccups so far is that pocket had had to resign after the allegedly busted
with cocaine at a party,
but facebook was still on a roll and really the only way was up
by September of 2006.
Facebook was open to anyone with an email address which set off a phenomenal
growth spat,
but 2006 was also the year we got our first real look at Mark Zuckerberg after
getting burned by his program back in 2004 Norendra hadn't given up,
along with the winklevoss twins and launched a massive lawsuit against
Zuckerberg.
This came to a head just as facebook was conquering the planet.
Unfortunately,
if a soccer bag,
this meant a lot of things from his past,
getting dragged Jonathan legal depositions over to excruciating years.
The press slowly learned down,
Zach,
that I could offer to use this private facebook data to his friends,
how had strung Narendra along while stealing his idea and how it even once
harvested passwords from facebook to hack the email accounts.
So journalists at the Harvard Crimson who were sympathetic to Narendra.
It was a litany of wrongdoing.
The source of scandal there could sink a lesser man,
but Zuckerberg,
he was lucky data privacy wasn't something that people really cared about yet
and he still had that aura of rebellious.
Cool.
It's hard now to believe that facebook ever had when he eventually settled with
no render out of for $65,000,000,
the world shrugged and went back to Sharon cat memes by 2008,
facebook had become a global phenomenon.
Aged 23 Zuckerberg was the youngest self made billionaire in history.
Even as the rest of the planets economy detonated in the financial crisis.
Facebook,
it just kept on growing as Zuckerberg had learned himself and his miserable
freshman year.
No one likes to feel alone,
but if you think the rest of this video is just going to be more of Zach back
becoming richer,
well casually stabbing colleagues in the back.
Well,
prepare yourself for a bit of a twist while the machiavellian soccer bag is
certainly a part of this story,
this another polyp to one we haven't really touched on in the rush to get to the
narrative,
and that's Zaka bag.
The philanthropist.
It started with $100,000,000 donation in 2010 to save new x public school system
from collapsing that same year,
[inaudible] signed the giving pledge,
committing himself to giving half of his fortune away to charity by 2015.
He and his future wife here,
we're going to be back to in a moment,
we'll be giving 99 percent of that fortune to charitable causes,
which was a record amount.
It's,
yeah,
we really get to the heart of what makes soccer bag tick and they'd all have the
minute Galatians and scandals.
It's worth remembering that at heart he's an idealist.
He really does the ones to make the world a better place,
whether through giving or encouraging us all to connect via facebook,
but he had soon set his sights even higher Zaka.
I didn't just want to change the world incrementally.
He wanted to actively shape.
It's to push everyone towards a better future whether they wanted to go there or
not.
Ironically,
it would be this noble impulse that soon sent him and his company on the road to
pr disaster
in October of 2014,
Mark Zuckerberg steps out of a bright orange helicopter and the tiny Indian
village of Chan to Ali.
It was a hot day,
the pregnant with humidity,
but Zuckerberg had more in his mind than the heat.
He was in Chengdu duty to change the world.
It had been a good four years to be mom because aca back in 2012 at married his
long time love Priscilla Chan.
Exactly one day after facebook had gone public for the first time,
about a year after that he would become a father.
Then there's the philanthropic work that February is Aka Berg on,
failed something called Internet.org,
which was later renamed free basics,
a vision plan and south where everyone would have access to an internet
connection.
Connectivity is a human rice.
It stated he was in India to make that vision a reality.
The idea that Zuckerberg pitch to the school,
children of Julie that October,
it was simple,
a free version of the Internet,
so that would give them access to 36 sites,
including of course facebook,
as he left the village to Chez and got back in his private helicopter,
Zaka the he must've felt like he was doing God's work bringing digital
civilization,
so the Internet,
barbarians of rural India or any not everyone saw it that way.
In fact,
to some Indian tech journalists sounded a lot like free basics violated net
neutrality.
Indeed,
they kind of saw it as more than digital era colonialism.
Soccer,
the could of course have countered this narrative by listening to the concerns
of these writers,
but he didn't.
Instead,
he does what he had done with sovereign ends,
Narendra and roll those years ago.
He struck first miss,
this was a bad move.
The scandal,
facebook's attacks stunned journalists.
The Guardian reports that the site automatically enrolls the profiles of users
into its empty nest and you're trying to see petitions at one point even signing
up those who had been dead for two years as one Indian generalist potentially
facebook came and shoved it sauce in all phases of the campaign was so
manipulative that galvanized India against facebook in February of 2016,
the country effectively outlawed free basics.
Now in the normal run of things,
this would have just been one misstep in the life of a company.
One more disaster that would simply be chalked up to experience,
but here's the thing about the free basics.
Debacle.
Zuckerberg,
he didn't learn.
What will you took away was that when the next scandal hit,
it would have to fight even harder and it wasn't long before that next scandal
arrived,
not six months later,
buzzfeed's editor,
Craig Silverman,
noticed a string of false stories emerging from one small town in Macedonia,
but blowing up a big time across all of facebook.
Nearly all involved the presidential candidates.
Donald trump,
strangely,
the stories and the sites they linked do seem to be multiplying and now for all
of them came from Macedonia as the campaign season drags on other stones to
emerge from further east,
specifically from Russia two years before an engineer at facebook.
It raised the alarm about unusual levels of activity coming from Russia.
This is reports.
It's just been dismissed.
People were wondering whether the Russians were using facebook to spread
propaganda.
Zuckerberg didn't think so.
Well,
November the 10th adjust two days off to donald trump's shock when in the
bitterly contested election,
he made a speech cooling those worried about fake news on his website,
crazy bus.
He wasn't telling the whole truth.
Facebook's own analysis published in 2017 would reveal Russian propaganda groups
that reached 126 million Americans during the election.
Rather than be concerns,
those Aka bag and his board,
they issued denials on January the sixth,
2017.
The CIA declan's that Russia has interfered in the election and to the social
media,
particularly facebook,
had played a major role outwardly.
Zuckerberg and his board do.
They simply kept on repeating that denials,
but behind the scenes panic,
it was beginning to set in throughout April,
facebook launched to crack down on fake news hoping to pull out ahead of the
scandal,
but by now it was too late by July,
Zuckerberg was claiming no evidence existed,
that Russian actors bought facebook ads,
Sony for hard evidence to emerge in September that indeed they did,
that Yom kippor he recorded a public video asking for you,
hardly hopes this new to approach would sue over the latest scandal,
unfortunately,
and even biggest scandal was already waiting in the wings on March the 17th,
2018 or joint report by the Guardian,
The New York Times,
and Britain's channel for revealed that a firm known as Cambridge Analytica had
used third party apps do harvest the data of 80 million facebook users and that
data had been used to try and influence votes everywhere from the US to Great
Britain to Mexico.
This data didn't just come from using suit,
stupidly installed these apps.
Some of the apps automatically harvested the data if that friends as well.
Crucially,
Zuckerberg,
he was aware of this facebook launched open graph software in April of 2010
specifically to sell data including the contents of private messages by the way,
to advertisers in May of that year.
Zuckerberg,
he wrote an op Ed in the Washington Post addressing users concerns,
but nothing was done about it until 2014,
and even then the changes,
they weren't applied retroactively.
Any company like Cambridge analytica that already had its claws into your data,
they didn't have to let go the resulting scandal.
It exploded like a small bomb staining the reputations of both facebook and Mark
Zuckerberg over 10 years after it was first used data from the facebook to hack
the emails of Harvard Crimson Journalists.
Zuckerberg was in trouble over a data privacy yet again,
or I need this time.
He had to testify on Capitol Hill.
On march the 20th,
2018,
the federal trade commission had launched an inquiry into facebook.
Greg Burson,
you and others had set up similar investigations that Spring moms talk about
privately told the facebook board that his company was now at war.
Yet still the scandals didn't stop at the time of this video is recording
facebook as a company lurching from scandal,
the scandal dragging it's found founder in its wake.
Among other things,
Zuckerberg burgs digital utopia has been accused of facilitating ethnic
cleansing and Myeloma aiding the harassment of survivors of mass shootings and
spreading negative propaganda about George Soros aged any 34.
Mark Zuckerberg has finally lost whatever veneer of cool he and his creation
once had rich,
powerful,
and utterly convinced of his own rightness.
He has refused,
cools to step down from facebook's board or do anything but to keep on fighting
isolation in the eye of a growing hurricane of scandal.
He no longer seems like the punk nerd who appended communication,
but like king lear raging at the sky as world crumbles around him.
Zuckerberg story,
it's not ovaries,
not yet 40,
but his biography as it stands today is one of wanting a strange morality tale
of Hubris theft and misplaced good intentions for our Internet age.
Whether the final act is one that ends in Dhaka,
bugs,
redemption,
or as destination is something that only time will tell.
So I really hope you enjoyed the video.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe.
We got brand new videos several days a week,
so hit that subscribe button in the notification bell so you actually find out
about these videos.
Subscribe Button doesn't do what it used to do on Youtube,
and as always,
thank you for watching.